[Applaudissements]
beau temps mauvais temps tous les jours
depuis le début du confinement christian
chatel fait la tournée du village de
janvry pour distribuer le pain ces
questions me boulanger et encore moins
livreurs les habitants de janvry quand
il ne l'appelle pas simplement par son
prénom
l'appel je suis là merci ça fait
quarante cinq jours 52 grands jeux c'est
plus qu'on se bat pour protéger tout le
monde pour faire tout ce qu'on peut
physiquement engagé pour que le virus ne
se développe pas dans la commune bonjour
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs ici le
cirque non pas en plus d'avoir repris la
distribution du pain pour éviter que
d'autres soit forcé de s'exposer au
virus
le maire du petit village à quelques 40
km de paris a distribué des masques fait
office de banque pour ses citoyens en
encaissant leur chèque et organisent un
marché public trois fois par semaine à
sa petite échelle christian chatel a
tout mis en oeuvre pour que les 650 âmes
de janvry n'est pas à quitter le village
au risque de croiser le chemin du corps
un avis russe le gouvernement il propose
des choses parce qu'il n'a pas le choix
de les faire dire qu' il va vous dire
ne mettez pas de masque c'est inutile
c'est juste parce que il n'ya pas de
masque s'il y avait eu des masques je
pense qu'ils auraient imposé qu'on mette
des masques tous là il ya on est dans un
drame économique dans le pays c'est vrai
et donc du coup il faut que les gens à y
travailler
sauf que
moi mes gosses ne seront pas de la chair
à canon et les les habitants de la
commune seront pas de la chair à canon
pour le développement économique de ce
pays
je me bats trop pour ça depuis des
semaines et des semaines
c'est comme ça que le maire voit la
réouverture des écoles dès lundi
prochain
il reproche au gouvernement d'agir selon
une logique économique bien plus que
pédagogique
il a donc décidé de ne pas rouvrir la
seule école à desservir les enfants de
janvry quand on voit toutes les
dispositions sanitaires qu'on est en
train de nous proposer pour ouvrir les
écoles le type qui a écrit ça il veut se
couvrir mais se couvrir de trois couches
il met les masques et 1000 parapluies et
y met l'abri antiatomique et pour dire
voyez j'avais imposer des conditions
sanitaires
sauf qu'elles sont irréalisables thomas
chazal est l'un des 300 maires de
l'ile-de-france qui ont signé une
pétition pour dénoncer le calendrier
imposé et demandé plus de temps
gouvernement pour se préparer à ouvrir
les écoles c'est plutôt une question de
stock de commandes pour pouvoir
appliquer le protocole qui à mon sens
est atteignable
puisque nous aurons que la moitié des
effectifs par classe et donc ça permet
d'avoir les distances entre enfants la
difficulté ça va plutôt être sur les
transitions entre les récréations où il
ya la mairie qui gère et l'éducation
nationale où là les groupes n'ont pas
droit de se croiser ce sera donc avec
une semaine de retard mais les écoles
doit rouvrir croit-il
l'un des grands défis des derniers jours
pour le maire chazal trouver
suffisamment d'enseignants
c'est sur la base du volontariat donc
les enseignants tous le droit de
le droit de devenir ou ne pas venir et
donc la grosse difficulté c'est de
mobiliser les enseignants et sur
certains groupes scolaires le manque se
fait ressentir à bign sur scène 39 % des
habitants vivent dans des logements
sociaux et beaucoup d enfants qui
habitent sont ceux qui se retrouvent du
mauvais côté du fossé des inégalités que
le gouvernement cherche à combler avec
un retour en classe les parents restent
libres de renvoyer leurs enfants à
l'école ou pas la scolarité peut
reprendre
il ne s'agit pas de forcer mais de
convaincre les parents a dit
gouvernement plus tôt cette semaine
emmanuel macron visitait une classe
d'enfants du personnel soignant pour
renforcer le message
moi je vais me laver les mains parce que
rufus toujours moment qu'il faut se
laver régulièrement mais bien des
parents ne croient pas que leurs enfants
pourront faire preuve de la discipline
nécessaire j'ai posé la question à mon
fils en lui disant ce que tu arriveras
maintenant quand je vais revoir mes
copains donc on va se faire des câlins
ils vont vouloir jouer ensemble enfin
ces essais en pensable au revoir sera
toujours temps de reprendre le chemin
des classes
après l'été mais surtout après que la
crise sanitaire soit passé pour le pire
lire ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada
en essonne